what's going on everybody welcome to
another python three tutorial video in
this video what we're going to be
talking about is some of the basic math
functions that we can do uh with the
module statistics that is that comes
with python 3. so the statistics module
basically gives us uh well statistics
type stuff so we get mean or average
right median mode standard deviation
variance um
and that's pretty much it anyway but
those kinds of things um so it's
actually a very useful module because in
python 2 7 you have to kind of code
these things yourself unless you have a
another module that you've downloaded
like a third-party module so anyway
let's go ahead and get started there so
let's go ahead and do import statistics
and now let's see what we can do here so
we're going to need an example list so
i'm just going to make an example list
we haven't really talked much about
lists we will get there
but for now just put a bunch of numbers
in these square brackets and that's
python list so just kind of you don't
have to copy my same numbers just put
some numbers in here
um and that'll do
so we have an example list now and now
we can use statistics to use this list
with the statistics module to kind of
get some information out of it so what
we can do is like
x equals statistics
dot mean and then we can find the mean
of the example list like that okay so
this is going to return to the x
variable what the mean of this example
list is so we can print that out so we
can say print x
run that
and this is the mean 9.6666
so there's a few other things that we
can do so i'm just going to edit this
dot mean to make it quicker
we can obviously do median like this we
can run that we get the median is six we
could do mode don't really need to show
it the other thing that we can do is
standard deviation which is really nice
so we can do standard deviation run it
and it turns out that we have a standard
deviation that's quite high and the
reason for that is in my list i had a 78
but we could
uh delete the seven there and make it
just an eight run this again and now we
have a much more realistic standard
deviation 2.2
another thing we can do is variance so
we can do that
and we get variance so
just a quick you know built-in module
that comes with python 3 that does some
of the more basic things that you're
going to find yourself needing
pretty early on since really
python is a pretty popular data analysis
tool so
anyways if anybody has any questions or
comments on that feel free to leave
those below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time